>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
SO MUCH SADNESS, BUT HONESTLY SO
MANY GREAT STORIES WERE IN UPPER
TEXAS DEMOCRATS, THE ONES WHO
FLED TO WASHINGTON, YOU SEE THE
FREEDOM FIGHTERS, THE ONES WHO
CAME ON A PILGRIMAGE WITH
NOTHING BUT A CASE OF
MILLER LITE AND THE CORONAVIRUS.
TURNS OUT THEY HAVE JUST CLAIM
SEVERAL MORE VICTIMS.
A WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL AND
WEAKER OF THE HOUSE NANCY PELOSI
HAS TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVID-19.
APPARENTLY GOT IT FROM THE
PILGRIMS OF TEXAS.
WE'LL HAVE AN UPDATE ON THE
CONDITIONS OF THE VICTIMS AND
THE SCALE OF THE SUPER-SPREADER
EVENT.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT, THERE ARE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO SELL
OUT TO CHINA.
IF YOU ARE AN UNSCRUPULOUS
FINANCE BROKER IN NEW YORK, FOR
EXAMPLE, YOU CAN JUST POP UP THE
CHINESE ECONOMY WITH BILLIONS OF
INVESTMENTS.
WALL STREET HAS BEEN DOING THAT
FOR DECADES.
YOU CAN DO YOUR PART BY
PRETENDING THAT THE REAL THREAT
TO THIS COUNTRY ISN'T THE RISE
OF CHINESE POWER AND AMBITION.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
THE REAL THREAT IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND HIS TEAM OF
SECRET AGENTS AND HIS NETWORK OF
MACEDONIAN CONTROL FARMS.
MAYBE PEOPLE WILL BELIEVE YOU.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY OR THE
RHETORICAL SKILLS TO DO EITHER
ONE OF THOSE THINGS BUT YOU
STILL WANT TO HELP?
WHAT IF YOU ARE A NOT VERY
BRIGHT THIRD STRING DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN FROM THE EAST BAY?
HOW CAN YOU DO YOUR PART?
WELL, YOU CAN JUST FIND A
CHINESE SPY AND THEN HAVE SEX
WITH HER REPEATEDLY.
THAT'S WHAT ERIC SWALWELL DID.
NOW WE ARE NOT GOING TO GET INTO
THE DETAILS OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BECAUSE THIS IS A FAMILY SHOW,
AND HONESTLY IT'S PRETTY CREEPY.
BUT WE CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
SPY'S NAME WAS FANG FANG.
SHE UNFORTUNATELY IS UNAVAILABLE
TO JOIN US ON THE SHOW.
AMAZINGLY, ERIC SWALWELL IS
STILL WITH US.
HE STILL AROUND.
IN FACT, HE'S BEEN ELEVATED TO A
SEAT ON THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, THE PERFECT REWARD
FOR THE BOYFRIEND OF A CHINESE
SPY IN THE CITY WITH COLLUSION
WITH FOREIGN POWERS.
ERIC SWALWELL EXITS HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH A CHINESE SPY
AND HE IS SENT TO THE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
IT DOES MAKE YOU WONDER.
SWALWELL, YOU WILL RECALL CAME
FROM NOWHERE 9 YEARS AGO TO BE
ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL AND
LONGEST-SERVING MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
TOOK AN AWFUL LOT OF MONEY TO DO
THAT, BUT SOMEHOW, DESPITE BEING
MEDIOCRE AND INARTICULATE AND
TOTALLY UNKNOWN AND VERY YOUNG,
ERIC SWALWELL HAD THE MONEY TO
DO THAT.
SO WHERE DID THAT MONEY COME
FROM?
GOOD QUESTION.
THE FBI DETERMINED THAT HE HAD
RAISED MOST OF THAT MONEY
ILLEGALLY.
A DONOR CALLED JAMES TONG HAD
SUPPLIED THE MONEY WITHOUT
COMPLYING WITH CAMPAIGN FINANCE
LAW.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHERE MOST OF
THAT CASH CAME FROM.
ERIC SWALWELL, OF COURSE PLEADED
IGNORANT.
AND BECAUSE HE IS DUMB, THE
AUTHORITIES APPARENTLY BELIEVED
HIM.
HOW DID HE KNOW HE WAS BREAKING
THE LAW?
THE GUY IS AN IDIOT.
THAT WAS A REASON.
SWALWELL BLUSHED AND PROMISED TO
NEVER DO IT AGAIN.
SO FROM THE VERY FIRST DAY,
THERE HAVE BEEN REAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT THIS ERIC SWALWELL
CHARACTER, IF THAT IS INDEED HIS
REAL NAME.
BUT YOU'D NEVER KNOW IT NOW.
SUCH IS THE MAGIC OF RESUME
LAUNDERING AND THE DISTORTING
POWER OF THE AMERICAN NEWS
MEDIA.
EVEN A WITH A WEAKNESS FOR SEX'
WITH CHINESE SPY'S OVERTIME
BEGINS TO LOOK LIKE HENRY
KISSINGER.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT ERIC
SWALWELL IS TODAY.
THE SPY'S BOY TOY IS NOW AN
ELDER STATESMAN HERE THAT'S HIS
PERSONAL ASSESSMENT OF HIMSELF.
LISTEN.
>> IT'S PRO WRESTLING, TO BE
HONEST.
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE BETTER
SUITED TO WORK AT THE WWE.
AND I SAY THAT ABOUT HIM BECAUSE
I'VE WORKED WITH HIM ON
MARIJUANA ISSUES.
I'VE WORKED WITH HIM ON OTHER
ISSUES, ESPECIALLY BEFORE TRUMP
TRUMPISM TOOK OFF.
THERE WERE TIMES WHERE HE WOULD
LAUGH AT HIMSELF ABOUT HOW
STUPID HE HAD TO ACT TO KEEP,
YOU KNOW, THE ACT GOING.
>> Tucker: I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON MARIJUANA ISSUES IT SAYS ERIC
SWALWELL.
BUT THE REST OF THOSE GUYS, THEY
ARE ALL CLOWNS, SAYS SWALWELL,
JUST IN HIS PLASTIC NOSE AND
APPLYING MORE GREASEPAINT.
IT IS JUST TOO FUNNY.
MEANWHILE, WASN'T IT JUST LAST
WEEK THAT WE GOT THAT PICTURE OF
ERIC SWALWELL GRINNING SHIRTLESS
ON A CAMEL AS HIS FAITHFUL
SERVANT OF COLOR LOOKED ON
ADORINGLY IN THE FOREGROUND?
ERIC SWALWELL, THE GREAT HUNTER,
LEOPARDS FEAR HIM.
THAT PARTICULAR CAMEL HUNT, BY
THE WAY, WAS PAID FOR BY
BUSINESS INTERESTS IN THE
PERSIAN GULF.
OH, SO WE ARE STARTING TO SENSE
A THEME HERE.
ERIC SWALWELL HAS A PROBLEM WITH
MONEY.
SHOCKED?
YOU SHOULD IT BE.
LIKE SO MANY PROGRESSIVES, ERIC
SWALWELL'S DEEPEST DESIRE IS TO
LIVE LIKE A RICH GUY OUT OF THE
MOVIE.
AND THAT IS DIFFICULT ON A
CONGRESSMAN'S SALARY.
SO CORNERS GET CUT.
HERE'S THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF
THAT.
CAMPAIGN FINANCE RECORDS
OBTAINED BY FOX NEWS SHOW THAT
ERIC SWALWELL SPENT THOUSANDS IN
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS.
MONEY HE RAISED TO RUN FOR
OFFICE.
MONEY HE IS PROHIBITED BY
FEDERAL LAW FROM SPENDING ON
HIMSELF.
HE SPENT THAT MONEY ON EXPENSES
THAT SEEMS ESPECIALLY LIKE
PERSONAL LUXURIES.
THOSE WOULD INCLUDE LEVEL RISE,
BOOZE DELIVERIES, HIGH END
STEAK HOUSES.
SOME OF THOSE EXPENDITURES
APPEAR VERY CLEARLY TO BE FOR
PERSONAL USE.
AND AGAIN, THAT'S ILLEGAL.
FOR EXAMPLE, ONE ORDER OF THE
ALCOHOL DELIVERY SERVICE WAS FOR
UNDER $10.
WAS THAT A CAMPAIGN EVENT?
NO.
THE MAN JUST WANTED HIS TEQUILA
SUNRISE AND HE WANTED IT NOW.
SO THE DOLLARS PAID FOR IT.
MOST INTERESTINGLY ON THIS
DISCLOSURE FORM, MORE THAN
$20,000 OF HIS CAMPAIGN
EXPENDITURES WENT TO THE
RITZ-CARLTON HOTEL IN HALF MOON
BAY CALIFORNIA.
NOT WEIRDLY COME OR MAYBE NOT SO
WEIRDLY, ERIC SWALWELL'S WIFE WN
EXECUTIVE THAT VERY HOTEL.
SO, CLEVER MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
THE HONEST ONES DON'T DO THINGS
LIKE THAT.
AND WHEN THEY DO THINGS LIKE
THAT, THEY TEND TO GET IN VERY
DEEP TROUBLE.
THE FACT THAT IT WAS JUST TWO
YEARS AGO THAT CONGRESSMAN
DUNCAN HUNTER OF SAN DIEGO SAID
IF A PARTY PLEADED GUILTY IN
FEDERAL COURT TO STEALING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN CAMPAIGN FUNDS THAT HE AND
HIS WIFE USED FOR PERSONAL
EXPENSES.
IN 2013, YOU WILL ALSO RECALL
CONGRESSMAN CHECK,
JESSE JACKSON JR. AND HIS WIFE,
BOTH DEMOCRATS ONE TO PRISON FOE
SAME THING.
WE ARE NOT SAYING THAT ERIC
SWALWELL SHOULD BE CHARGED BY
SLEEPING WITH A CHINESE LIE OR
BY MISUSING CAMPAIGN FUNDS.
WE ARE GOING TO NEED AN
IMMEDIATE FEDERAL INVESTIGATION,
POSSIBLY A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
NO WHAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE
EXACTLY ON DONALD TRUMP.
IT IS JUST AS DESTRUCTIVE
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT HAS DRAWN
US CLOSE TO A FOREIGN ADVERSARY
WHO WAS NOT OUR FRIEND.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
OH, ERIC SWALWELL, SOMEONE WHO
WAS CLOSE TO A FOREIGN ADVERSARY
IS NOT OUR FRIEND.
REALLY HOW CLOSE?
[LAUGHS]
SO, WHAT'S GOING ON WITH ERIC
SWALWELL AND WHY DON'T WE
DESERVE TO KNOW WHEN A SITTING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE IS DOING WITH
SPIES?
AND WHAT DOES HE THINK OF THIS